how long does it take you to finish the
first draft of a screenplay
that can i mean that certainly just
varies i think on the subject matter
you know if you're in a in a dramatic
genre
i think it'll take a bit longer comedy
it's not my strongest suit but i do love
it i think comedy is
extremely hard to write i mean how are
you gonna craft
all these jokes i mean that's that's
wild to me
um but because i've been living in this
like suspense
thriller mystery world for quite a while
now i would say that
a first completed feature feature script
um probably takes me
two or three weeks for the first draft i
think my
my fastest draft that i ever did which
was like a true life drama
so you know was different i was pulling
from my own experiences that one took me
about a week
and then i was trying to submit it to a
writing competition i was trying to like
you know one of those one of those big
writing competitions
so i was under the gun to get it done
that was all i was doing is working on
that script
and then my shorts i mean my shorts all
take
an hour or two to craft you know a short
film is a little bit different at least
the ones that we make because
we understand what our limitations are
we we try to make our short films
something that we know that we can
create for a certain you know kind of
respectable budget
um and so knowing those parameters
i know exactly kind of what where my
story can go and where my story needs to
kind of like find a way to
to stay within the bounds so that could
just take me a couple hours
so you're wanting to do horror thriller
or like true like true crime
oh no i i do love uh horror thriller
i i'm just i'm a huge like mystery
junkie like i just love the good mystery
it doesn't have to be true if it is true
cool like it's exciting
um but i do just love a good mystery
like thrilling like any time i can be on
the edge of my seat with the thrills i'm
i'm really there for it so and then if
you can throw a twist in i mean
that's all you need do you remember the
tv show unsolved mysteries
yes oh it was terrifying it was
terrifying with the music and they're
still unsolved you're like right
this murderer is walking among us
unsolved right
or there was one story where they hadn't
seen a woman and the last
they reported she might have been
wearing some old clothes that were wet
walking down a country road
and they weren't sure if that was she
was still alive and where did she go
yeah and i'll never forget that just
that scene that they had had an actor
replay her and she was still alive and
she wasn't harmed but i
it was murky about what had happened
right that is like terrifying right
there
and there's just something in that and
there's no gore
in it it's just this sort of unknown
where did she go she was walking but
then later on you found out that she
was fine or they never found either way
see that that is jumping off point that
is that
that to see so clearly is like i see it
let's jump from here all right let's
figure out what did happen this woman
either before or after
probably not after because we're going
to leave that mystery out there
right i love that you should write that
well i guess that she they
thought maybe she got clothes from a
clothesline and so then she was like and
for some reason she was drenched and and
some but some passersby saw her on a
country road walking interesting and it
was never determined
she was never found and it was never
determined where she was going but that
image of just this mysterious woman on
this lone road was just so
vivid yeah you see it so clearly i i
would be interested to see
a script about that one yeah
not sure it'll make it to the afternoon
but yeah
we'll try to write a little email future
[Music]
future notes to karen yes exactly once a
draft is done
what are you doing from there first
draft sure
yeah first draft i mean
i'm i'm i will always probably have
certain scenes that are going to be my
favorite
among a draft and so i'll probably kind
of like go back to those and play
favorite and like live in those scenes a
little bit and try and tighten them up
or explore what else could be done there
um but i've as i grow as a writer i
realize that
that begs the question why aren't all of
the scenes your favorite
you know if that question is coming to
mind if you do find yourself having
favorites
well then you need to go back to the
ones that are not your favorite those
are where you really need to be
living and going back to to figure out
what's going on there
and tighten that and lift it up because
again like i said once if you intend to
to make this a production yourself or if
you intend to ask somebody else to fund
it or
another production company to to come on
board i mean
don't waste anyone's time don't waste
your own time like make this the best
possible thing
so after first draft i may walk away
from it for just a little while like a
day or so
um probably not more than a day at that
and and just kind of like
keep rereading it read it again read it
over again watch another watch a movie
kind of like see what characters they
created and it doesn't have to be a
similar move it can be any movie just a
movie that
you know kind of gives you that flutter
of excitement
and see what they did really well and be
like okay am i doing that well or is my
character's journey really really clear
are their struggles really clear
are they likable all of that um i think
once you start once you finish your
first draft
you have an instinctual
awareness as to where you need to go
back and polish it up
and so that's that's it i'm just
polishing
polish waxing on waxing off polishing
that script
um pretty much until i just can't stand
it anymore
and all of a sudden now i've seen it
it's actually probably become the second
draft with all of those
those tune-ups and tweaks um and of
course aaron is very involved in all
this process it's usually both of us
working together the whole time
so he's probably been involved maybe
he's even taken the script just for
himself for a few days to like
tighten up and put some suggestions in
there um
and then once we feel like okay we've
we've reached the maximum of what we're
capable of now let's send it out
for some feedback from our our trusted
friends and family members really
our parents quite a bit of our parents
are like reading all of our stuff and
sending us back their thoughts
it's nice are you ever worried you might
scare them with something you've written
like oh it would be my greatest pleasure
i hope so i mean like taking it a little
too far like
should we show mom and dad um
not i mean somewhat like we we have
actually scared them
with val with the vowel script in fact
um so that that was great that was great
feedback to hear that they were creeped
out
um and yeah yeah just to scare them i
mean they
they are creative and they didn't uh
well they're creative in their own ways
as well not exactly in the same camp as
us but creative in their own rights
and and they give fantastic feedback and
we also appreciate that they're from a
different generation
so important like we i know that there's
uh there's some there's something to
being
niche and you know kind of speaking to
like just maybe your own specific
audience
but personally i kind of want to i want
to cast my net i want to be
something that you know i want to be the
sixth sense where really anyone of any
age can go and check that out and really
enjoy it and so when someone from a
different
age group can read my work and let me
know from their point of view like this
this is kind of you know cringy i don't
like how this character does this or i
don't understand this that's a wonderful
piece of information because
people need to understand what we're
about to create they absolutely need to
know
if either it's tech based or it's just
kind of maybe something
that the characters do and that's more
of like a generational thing
okay now i can explain the way that this
character is doing this weird
you know generational like ritual like
social media or what have you
in a better light so that now this this
different generation can understand it
as well
sure because if you think about carrie
if there had been social media
during that time oh my gosh what a
different
different turns it could have taken yeah
and uh yeah
well with horror personally i can't
stand
technology and horror unless now there
are some
some caveats like i just recently
watched host on
shutter um fantastic if i'm to
understand correctly the story um the
director
had done this as like a practical
practical joke it's a
scary story that happens over zoom he
did something as a practical joke for
his friends
the story kind of went viral in some way
and then he got funded by shutter
what you know these are the details i
read on some article um and then he made
this movie and i think the budget for
the movie was around like thirty
thousand dollars
and it all happens on zoom and that was
a time i watched that movie and i was
like
wow i felt like he did something even
though it's all living here in the
screen you know the whole movie takes
place right there
i felt like it was it was he he had
really made it tight he had really made
sure that it was tight and
the characters were interesting to
follow and i i just loved what he
had created um and so that's where that
gets me into the social media like the
technology aspect
of horror or scary stories
if you're just living in a regular world
like a modern day world and all of your
characters can
quickly you know pick up their cellular
phone that has connection everywhere on
the globe
and you know dial anyone the stakes are
they
they naturally are lower you know your
characters have so many more lifelines
to kind of save themselves so you as the
writer
need to figure out okay straight away i
either need to cut the ties of
technology
either explain to my viewer for some
reason or another there's no service in
this area or
you know whatever it's like you try and
come up with something as new
and as original as you can or you're
going to set it in a time period that's
not quite techn
technologically advanced like we're
living in at this at present moment
um a lot of my stories kind of lean a
little bit more in the 90s like i try to
kind of tell stories more in the 90s
because
certainly technology is just on the
precipice of booming but it is not
like in our hands like right here
constantly as a lifeline
um and that's really more in like the
horror genre that i'm working in
but i feel like hereditary that was a
modern story and i didn't see a lot of
technology used in it but it didn't feel
like it was missing either right i agree
so i think that they did a really
elegant way of handling that so that you
know
it's it's kind of exciting it's a new
challenge for writers
where as technology can continue to
advance how are you gonna tell the
scariest story
without you know kind of when i see tech
on screen it kind of
i don't know it's different from seeing
an old musky like
out in the woods english manner you know
where your characters are trapped versus
they're in a modern home with like
everything at their disposal and they're
you know at the touch of their hand
um you know it's different and as a
writer you need to try and figure out
how to
tell that tell that story the best you
can yeah hereditary could have actually
been in the 70s if they just
changed their wardrobe in the clothes
exactly it could have actually been that
you know just
had that feel to it yeah exactly yeah
and i i don't really recall much
tech but i also don't recall being like
where is the tech
i think that this the characters weren't
in situations where they had to
call each other that often they were all
like living in the house right
if i'm thinking didn't he go to a party
the son though he was at like this party
and he was bored and
yeah he didn't fit in or whatever well
the young girl
doesn't fit in as well
and then that cut to me in the movie
theater like
we paid money for this like i mean now
like i say that lightly because i love
that i
saw that but i couldn't eat for probably
like a day after seeing that movie
i was so grossed out i was so
traumatized there was a grown man next
to me that was like
yelling out he was scared and i was like
oh my god i like what did i get myself
into
it's so scary but it was well worth it
so worth it and so rare you know i i
don't feel like i have that experience
that often
so i'm so grateful that that we did get
that experience and
i hadn't seen the trailer either so i
was really going into that movie
like what i went in fairly blind too and
yeah people were freaked out in the
theater and it was an interesting
experience to be amongst everybody well
done to them i'm just so happy with that
i sure miss it i hope those experiences
come back thank you me too
they they will hopefully they will one
day couple years
maybe yeah
you